hello believe nation I serve dimension
II series with the goal to try to hang
on people who had a lot more success at
us and hopefully by spending a little
more time with them some of their
mindset their belief systems our way of
thinking seeped into us to help us
become the best version of ourselves so
today we're going to learn some of the
very best advice from some of the Forbes
billionaires
so every year Forbes make a list of the
richest people in the world many of them
are entrepreneurs and I thought it'd be
a fun idea to take some of the very best
advice from the list of the wealthiest
most successful Forbes billionaires to
help us get strong and as always as
you're watching the video if you hear
something that really resonates with you
please leave it down the comments below
and put quotes around it as well so
other people can be inspired to enjoy
[Music]
when I started Microsoft I didn't think
of it as all that risky I mean I was so
excited about what we were doing
it's true I could have gone bankrupt but
you know I had a set of skills that were
highly employable and in fact my parents
were still willing to let me go back to
Harvard and finish my education if I
wanted to you've always got a job with a
bill and the only thing that was scary
to me wasn't quitting and starting the
company was when I started hiring my
friends and they expected to be paid and
then we had customers who went bankrupt
customers that I'd counted on to come
through and so then I got this
incredibly conservative approach that I
wanted to have enough money in the bank
to pay a year's worth of payroll even if
we didn't get any any team was coming in
and I'm almost heard of that the whole
time we have about 10 billion now which
is pretty much enough for the next year
anyway I if you're going to start a
company and take so much energy that you
know you better overcome your your
feeling of risk I don't think that you
necessarily if you're going to start a
company should do it at the start of
your career I think there's a lot to be
said for working for company learning
how they do things you know if you're
young it's hard to go leased premises
they made that hard for you couldn't
rent a car when you were under 25 at the
time so I was always taking taxis to go
see customer and the people would you
know people say we're going to go have a
discussion in the bar well I could go to
the bar and you know that's fun because
I'll tell you when people are first
skeptical and then go this kid doesn't
know anything then when you show them
you've really got a good product you
know something they actually tend to go
overboard and they think whoa you know
they know a lot let's really do an
incredible amount of these people so are
you at least in this country was a huge
asset for us once we reached a certain
threshold it is hard it's hard to hire
old older people because they'll be a
little bit conservative about whether
they should come in and take the risk
and it took three or four years before
we could go out into the normal sort of
employment pool but those those problems
that come with starting the firm you
better think of those as part of the the
pleasure part of the the challenge that
that is part of the excitement I was
just wondering what is what would you
consider to be the worst investment
you've ever made the worst investment I
ever made how long do you have
I've made some very bad ones but that
doesn't really bother me I am that they
bother the shareholders but that's
another question yeah
you know you're going to make you make
mistakes in life I mean there's no
question about it you don't want to make
them under big decisions you know who
you marry and things like that so
there's no way I'm going to make a lot
of business and investment decisions
without making some mistakes I may try
to minimize them I don't I don't dwell
on them at all I don't I don't look back
that the biggest mistakes are the ones
that actually don't show up they're the
mistakes of omission rather than
Commission we've never lost that much
money on any one investment but it's the
things that I knew enough to do that I
didn't do we've we have missed profits
of as much as you know maybe ten billion
dollars in things that I knew enough to
do and I didn't do now the fact that is
by Microsoft wayback is not a forgone
opportunity because I didn't know enough
to make that decision
but there have been other investments
where I did know enough to make the
decision and for one reason another I
either didn't do it at all or I did it
on a small scale as I was sucking my
thumb when I should have been writing
checks you know basically and and and
you know those don't show up there's no
place where it shows missed
opportunities but I've missed some big
one the triumphs in life are partly
trying because you know that everything
isn't going to be a triumph and and and
I would never get too hung up on
mistakes I know a lot of people that
really agonize over them and it just
isn't worth it I mean tomorrow's another
day and you live it forward and just go
on to the next thing and we know from
our past experiences that big things
start small you know the biggest oak
starts from an acorn and you've got to
recognize you want to do anything new
you've got to be willing to let that
acorn grow into a little sapling and
then finally into a small tree and maybe
one day it'll be a big business on its
own and in fact that's one of the models
for one of your initiatives and forgive
my my pronunciation of the Latin but
Greta team for Ock what does that mean
to you well it means step by step
ferociously and it's the motto for Blue
Origin
and basically you can't skip steps you
have to put one foot in front of the
other things take time you there are no
shortcuts and but but you want to do
those steps with you know passion and
ferocity the main thing is just when
you're starting something it's um it's
just kind of hard you need to be pretty
headstrong about it or and they're gonna
be all these challenges that come up and
I think the main thing that you need to
do is just not give up right and and
kind of know what you want to do and you
know the best entrepreneurs that who
I've met don't really start companies
because their goal is to build a company
they do it because they want to make a
change in the world and help people and
I think if you if you kind of stay true
to that and and if you just focus on
kind of powering through no matter what
the the challenges are that will
inevitably come up in your path then um
you'll find that there are lots of tools
that are available and a lot of people
who will help you build what you're
building pick things up for yourself
come to your own judgments then simply
conform to conventional ways of thinking
conventional ways of dressing
conventional ways of acting that a lot
of this a lot of things are based on
fashion even morality at times is based
on fashion
it was once that yeah slavery was once
not considered not to be immoral you
know people in people are shocked that
the ancient Greeks had slaves that we
had slavery in this country as recently
as you know a hundred and thirty hundred
forty years ago so there are more moral
value have to really go back to first
principles and think things out for
yourself whether the scientific
principles or moral principles or
business ideas or product ideas you have
to think things out yourself I believe
that family and personal life and
business or professional life is not
only compatible is necessary you will
have a better professional life with a
good personal life and family life that
if you don't have a good personal life
my family life I think I don't know aunt
and the contrary and it's very clear
that that the good personal life make
you stronger you are stronger for the
challenges you are walking I think I
don't believe in working 20 hours of 16
hours of 14 hours when you work too much
is because your job is beyond you you
are not controlling this you are not
doing with your job if you need to be 15
hours 16 hours because you are not
organized then you don't have delegation
of your responsibilities and and I don't
believe that in any business in any
activity you need to work 15 or 16 hours
and you don't have time for yourself or
for your family for anyone
when I graduate from university and
before you know for three years I tried
fill in the universities to apply jobs
for 30 times got rejected
I went for a police we didn't know
you're not good I went to you know even
the KFC when KFC came to check our blood
a variety 24 people went for the job 23
people accepted I was only with guys and
we went for please five people all of
them accepted I was the only guard in
our respectful people so for me being
turned down rejected oh by the way I
told you that I would apply for Harvard
for 10 times rejected I know you really
are sorry now 10 times you wrote them
and said I'd like to come to Harvard
yeah and then I told myself somebody I
should go teach there buddy
if you want to make a quick buck you can
do it a lot of different ways you can
cheat somebody you can misrepresent
something you can go manipulate the plot
system to get an advantage but if you
want to if you want to be successful
over a long period of time I believe you
need to be to focus first of all on
creating value for others and that's an
O that's I've had people well that's
naive
that's utopian no it isn't because why
will the customers want to pay you
anything over a long period unless
you're creating value for them why would
your your employees want to work for you
and if they did they didn't have any
alternative why do they want to give
their best efforts why do they want to
get excited why would they wake up at
night with ideas if you're in a
community a plan in the community unless
you're creating value for that community
why would the community want you there
if you're polluting and hurting people
and not contributing anything to the
community so long-term success starts
with being dedicated to creating value
for others it's it's not altruism if my
whole philosophy is is to have a system
of mutual benefit where both parties
gain a society based on win-win the only
thing that you can control that
influences success in life is how hard
you work how honest you are and how well
you deal with others you can control
those are variables but those variables
it you can't control how lucky you are
although the more you work the luckier
you get you have no influence on the
intellectual capabilities that God did
or did not give you but you can work as
hard as possible you can be scrupulously
honest so that people respect you and
you can get along with others because
nobody does anything by themselves did
you have to pay a price to you
personally no I think that everything is
an either-or you there is a price and
everything you can study or you can go
out and play you can just
for two others or you can try to hog the
credit you can be honest and suffer the
consequences or you can lie cheat and
steal and short-term maybes in advance
but long-term you are better off as
you'll work harder you are better off if
you're honest and you are better off if
you give others credit and get them to
help you with by helping them what do
you tell others who try to strike that
balance between family and work and
where you have you know the answer of
either/or is invariably yes you can't go
all in one direction you cannot walk
away from your family for your career on
the other hand if you walk away from
your career from your career for your
family you're not going to have the
money to support the family and parents
all the time are making those kinds of
choices between career and family they
do some of both and you try to blend the
two and that may not be the perfect
answer but that's a practical answer
that I've always told you on people when
they go off to college you have to study
and you have to get good grades but you
certainly should have a good time as
well because that's part of your growing
up experience and there's no point in
leading life to suffer all the time you
want to enjoy life as well as the next
person so it's some balance some blend
between the two I want to talk about
dreams for a second
and in my kids literally in a dream when
I was in college I was sure that I've
been admitted by a clerical error really
a computer error and because of that an
irrational fear I'd be spent called on
the bus and surveys fear knows this is
true but it turns out because of that
anxiety I woke up literally with a dream
it was kind of a strange dream it went
like I think I could download the entire
web on the phone
chitters they were lying around and that
probably seemed pretty crazy to most
people but I stayed up all hours in the
middle of the night doing some math and
it seemed actually pretty plausible all
something actually didn't keep any of
the webpages you only couple links and
then sort of figure it out given all
that data that'll take a couple weeks
and I told my advisor that and he sort
of laughed to me and of course there
wasn't a year or two but at the end of
that we had a way to rank web pages and
no top searches all and eventually
surgicenter the picture and you know the
rest
and that became Google Books and rings
everyone followed every
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed I'd love to know what
did you think of this video did you
enjoy did you learn from it what was
your favorite clip and what was the
biggest message that you took from this
video what are you going to immediately
apply to your life or to your business
leave it down in the comments below and
I'm going to join in the discussion
finally I also want to give a quick
shout of the kree stuff thank you so
much for picking up a copy of my book
your one word and posting that funny
picture on Instagram that included the
little tiny Teemo on the side I really
really really appreciate your support so
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love please
the one wonders has we focused on the
short-term and money coming in when
creating company because otherwise the
company will for die so that the I think
that a lot of times people think like
creating company is going to be fun I
would say it's not it's really not that
fun when their periods of fun and their
periods of which were just awful
and particularly if you CEO of the
company you actually have a distillation
of all the worst problems in a company
so there's no point in spending your
time on things that are going right so
you only spend on things on your time on
things that are going wrong and and
there are things that are going wrong
that other people can't can't take care
of so you're like the worst you have a
filter for the crappers problems in the
company the most pernicious and painful
problems so I would say it's I think you
have to feel quite compelled to do it
and have a fairly high pain threshold
and there's a friend of mine who says
like starting companies like sharing
exhibits and eating glass and distant
rooster that we're starting to be abuzz
part is that you're going to be
constantly facing the extermination of
the company because most most startups
fail like 90% ugly 99% of of startzville
so I bet that's the staring in to give
this part you can't constantly saying
okay if I don't get this right the
company will die should be quite
stressful quite stressful and and then
the eating glass part is you've got
you've got to do you've got to do the
problems you put your go to work in the
problem that the company needs you to
work on that problems you want to work
on and so that but that's you end up
working on problems that that you'd
really wish you weren't working on and
so that's the eating glass part then
that goes on for a long time so how do
you keep your focus on the big picture
when you're constantly faced with we
could be out of business in a month
well it's just a very small percentage
of mental energies on the on the big
picture like you know you know where you
generally heading for and and the
special path is going to be some sort of
zigzagging thing in that direction it
cry not to deviate too far from the path
that that you want to be on but you're
going to have to do that some degree but
I don't want to I don't want to diminish
that I mean I think the product the
profit motive is it is a is a good one
if the rules of an industry are properly
set up so there's only fundamentally
wrong with pub but in fact profit just
means that people are paying you more
for whatever you're doing then you're
spending to create it that's a good
thing and if you're not if that's not
the case then you'll be out of business
and rightfully so sure you're not adding
enough value there's a Latin expression
which i think is great I love it within
a now very old movie called the Dead
Poets Society but the line of the movie
was carpe diem seize the day the
opportunities are there but you got to
reach out and pick them up you've got to
grab at them some of you may have
already done that at the you and your
classes and other students that you met
in your extracurricular activities but
grab them don't be afraid to make a
mistake because you know what you can do
if you grab the wrong one
drop it and pick up another one it's
okay
seize the day I think back of all of the
the luck
but also the times that were in front of
me to seize the day I don't know what
got me to drop out of business school
and come to Microsoft my parents thought
I was a whack job
neither one of them graduated college
and they thought this was really a wild
idea I was lucky I seize the day
Microsoft one day some guys fly in from
from IBM and all of a sudden we figure
out we could actually
provide all the software they need for
this thing that became the personal
computer people bill Paul they have the
wisdom to seize the day when that
opportunity presented itself and yet
when you think of all the opportunities
when I think back of all the
opportunities I've had the one that was
most important was an opportunity I got
1969 sitting in my junior high school
class I was in a public junior high not
very stimulated at the time and over the
loudspeaker they said that what private
high school in our area that I'd never
heard of with giving scholarship tests
that weekend I told my mother I wanted
to take him she said that's fine as long
as you get a scholarship because we
can't afford to send you there but
that's really where I got switched down
switched on and math switched on
personally energized in a way that never
never could be turned back and I'm very
thankful for that opportunity yes
there's a lot of lots in opportunity but
there's a lot of seizing the day and I
encourage you all to reach out and carpe
diem really seize the opportunities that
are in front of you I've been working
I've been in business 269 years since I
was 12 and every time well after the
first dozen or so businesses I realized
that the only way to get ahead was to do
things different differently than the
way it was being done and then I came to
learn which I finally learned it my rug
young age that if you do things
differently success will follow you like
your shadow and you can't get rid of it
so that's what I did
so people doubted me because people just
didn't do what I what I would do it's a
matter of Tainted finding out what it is
that an end
three does and identify the opportunity
to as to how to do it differently and
then being enough of a risk-taker to
actually do it differently
so people doubted me because nobody
thought of doing it the way that I did
and nobody had the they didn't have the
they were satisfied with the status quo
and I'm never satisfied with this better
school